if you look at the life cycle of a
startup you usually want to invest in
the very early stages of that company
people often call these status the
pre-seed stage to the seed stage this is
a terminology that is widely accepted in
the community there is a widely
respected napkin from the big we see
from 0.9 and they Define the precede
stage in the way that you can see it
here with these typical evaluations and
this then can be contrasted by the seed
stage in the pre-seed stage the company
often doesn't even have a product it's
more or less just a team so you do need
to make your investment decision just on
the merits of this team contrasted to
the seed stage often the first prototype
of a product already exists maybe
already the first one two three
customers have been acquired and so this
does give you a couple of additional
data points so then base your investment
decisions on